Elon on Twitter free speech is back as
long as you don't make fun of me
yeah that was pretty funny I mean I
didn't what was going on with the
impersonation stuff or like he was like
unless people strictly put
or explicitly Say parody in their
username I will suspend those accounts
Mr Ethan Klein took that as a challenge
yeah I saw he got permaband yeah he's
gone yeah
yeah so but the thing that was confusing
me is like Elon was like oh nothing has
changed about content moderation at all
but then like he's tweeting about these
policies yeah as if they're new so did
he change it and like would you have
always gotten banned if you did this
it's a good question I don't know
I'm not a big it's just funny the way
he's tweeting it's like he's tweeting as
if Twitter is his like Pet Project now
yeah and he's he's the one leading
everything and he's just making the
rules I mean what did any of us expect I
I love it I mean I don't like it when
I'm saying I love okay here
I mean tell me if you agree with this
sure
with this happening like with Twitter
just melting down right now I mean this
is just it just feels like we're
watching a train wreck right yeah and
The Meta layoffs that are supposedly
happening this week where they're
gutting like half the company or
something like that I think they have 82
000 employees and apparently they're
getting rid of like a significant chunk
of them I mean I don't mean to like
Revel in people losing their jobs but I
do
take a weird amount of like
pleasure and seeing social media like
dissolve shading freuda yeah don't you
which is a weird thing to say as people
who have like made our livings off of it
yeah
yeah I don't know but don't you feel the
same way it's like we're at this weird
point where like Tick Tock might get
banned Facebook is the bottom performer
of the S P 500 it was the last one I'm
pretty sure and now Twitter is melting
down yeah I like that Mark Zuckerberg is
getting kicked in his balls I like that
because I think that's funny yeah
and I like that Twitter's becoming a car
crash
but in a way it does make me sad
because you like Twitter
I I want to still like Twitter do you
I like I want it to be fun still it's
not really was anyone having fun not all
anyone does is complain about it uh yeah
now it sucks now it's not that exciting
and anyone anytime anyone like deletes
Twitter or deletes Instagram they're
like oh [ __ ] my life got so much better
yeah I'm fine with Twitter but Burning
Up in Flames and the fact that he owns
it I think it's even funnier if it just
completely expires if it just like hits
the [ __ ]
you gonna pay for the check
I don't I don't know I don't think so
I can't are you guys
check I mean would we pay for it like
TMG Studios
like
um for our studio account you know I'm
Petty I don't want to give him any money
yeah but even by going on Twitter you're
giving them money
that's true
that's very true
pain to be like look at me
no but I I know I I don't like want to
pay for it but apparently
you get better features and stuff like
that
I'm trying to I'm trying to see both
sides here yeah yeah I don't I never use
Twitter I literally don't so if I didn't
pay for this it would make zero
difference for me and I don't care about
how my profile looks yeah like I don't
even use it so why does it matter like I
barely tweet anymore so why does it
matter what my profile looks like yeah
Twitter is uh
I don't know I don't know if I'm gonna
pay I mean like I I feel like
there it could potentially make it
better the platform in that less
marketing less reliant on ads more
relying on like people paying to use
Twitter so they're catering to the
customers of Twitter which are now the
users not the advertisers that seems
like kind of a good thing that's a good
argument what I think will happen is he
will take all of our money and the
product will continue to be worse and
worse and he will promise things that
will never happen yes I totally see that
happening and I kind of hope it does
yeah I don't know I mean I pay for
Netflix and that thing sucks so
yeah that keeps getting worse too yeah
what difference does it make
I mean yeah you know what [ __ ] it I'm
gonna pay for it because like are you
even a real person without a blue check
no yeah that's like kind of the point is
that it like encourages people to be
like I'm not a bot look at me yeah
because that's like the main problem
okay then how will everyone know that
I'm better than them
see that I don't know yeah they need to
figure that out they need a super check
they they need one of those for sure
it's the same checkpoint it's just
bigger yeah
different colors still not still white
so slightly bigger yeah yeah
yeah
and juicier maybe a little like like a
boss on it yeah there we go a little
juice here
oh you got the juicy check yeah
yeah I'm Juiced up it's like 10 a month
you pay 10 a month for that yep
yeah yeah they need like nothing the
more you pay the bigger your check is
yeah yeah
50 a month shit's just your whole
profile it's one big yeah blue covers
your name two huge blue ass cheeks if it
covers your name covers everything just
big as [ __ ] who is this yeah the check
it just gets more Caked Up Yeah the more
you pay it no it just turns into it like
a it's just a sexualized
um
like just like humanoid yeah you can't
tell what gender it is just as a fat
[ __ ] ass exactly and the check mark
is the check mark
is the check mark its head or its cheeks
like does the check mark become the
cheeks the cheeks
for sure oh so then the check like
slowly warps into the butt crack yes and
that's like yeah it was like a line that
like goes down the left cheek and then
up the back yeah and then that [ __ ] is
just like
dude it's got like the the pose where
the feet are to the side like on the
ground it's looking back exactly yeah
oh my God damn this check mark is fat
how much are you paying for Twitter what
would that be uh that'd be up
okem
fat ass check mark a what like I said a
Pog nice
yeah exactly
badass check mark what is this if you
don't pay the eight dollars your tweets
will be suppressed but yeah I I was uh I
read this
yes it says if you don't pay the eight
dollars your tweets will be suppressed
by an algorithm not making this [ __ ] up
he said it to a room of investors
yesterday and claimed this would solve
hate speech you'll have to scroll really
far to see unverified users it's not
it's not it's not a bad idea but again
like yeah it's it's the problem is like
Anonymous Bots and people saying
whatever the [ __ ] they want so yeah if
that gets suppressed that's probably
better but the argument against it is
like well that's not free speech then
yep
yeah now there's a that was a gateway
yeah
I mean I don't know it's interesting but
the whole thing is like dude what's
interesting about this to me is that he
gets he buys a company he gets plugged
in and then he's like oh I'm just gonna
Implement all these things that are
obvious and it's like they've probably
thought of this [ __ ] before yeah
this has been like one of the main tech
companies for the last 10 years they've
probably thought of this and realized
that it wouldn't work for a certain
reason yeah the context I think for
Twitter a while ago I don't think a
while ago people would have paid for it
I think it's almost one of those things
where Twitter had to be so in like
insufferable now people are willing to
pay for it maybe you know what I mean
like Twitter used to be so much fun yeah
no one would have paid for it back then
because it's like [ __ ] you yeah yeah you
know I'm just gonna we're just gonna go
over here yeah
you know wherever here is Instagram
whatever but now all social media
platforms suck ass so I think people now
are willing to entertain all right eight
dollars and you get the Bots out of
there and I can carry my timeline and
yeah exactly a bit more reminiscent of
what it used to be okay cool I like
seeing this like melt down right now
just because it just seems like a
dumpster fire but also I kind of hope
that it works
um because I would like Twitter to be
fun again yeah
Twitter I don't know
good it might depend what Pockets you're
in but I used to feel like the whole
thing was everyone trying to say stupid
jokes whatever
and yeah now it's obviously so motivated
by news and getting people angry which
just stinks yeah social media oh it
should just be podcasting yeah yeah
yeah you know yeah you should just be
tweeting videos that are minimum 60
minutes long
about everything you can't you can't get
digestible opinion you know what let's
go the other way
extreme Nuance exactly with everything
yes yeah dude the fun thing about
posting mean jokes about Elon Musk on
Twitter is you know there's uh starting
what I can't read starting a huge chance
he's actually going to read it and it
will hurt his feelings
yeah
now we should tweet Elon [ __ ] my wife at
him
yes we should 100 permaband yeah
damn dude oh here's a riveting post from
pop crave
look at this thing that happened yeah
did you ever crave pop yeah
you're finding yourself craving that
dose of Pop Culture yep what's a good
Twitter account for that
I think pop crave
that's a good one are your headphones
keep popping up yeah sorry you're good
there we go
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
popping